I'm a really great mine hahahahaha hi
and welcome to Friday re first of all my
name is grace Helbig
I should have why hi I'm grace Helbig if
you don't know now you know and you
should this is the new thing I'm trying
click Subscribe here right now at the
beginning of this video so that you
don't get to the end and feel like you
wasted your time and do not want to
subscribe subscribe now while you're in
your blissful ignorant state of what my
brand actually is hey hello and welcome
to Friday I read for those of you that
do not know fried diary is a look back
at my week in blog diary format tears
and look back at some of the things that
have happened to me this week I went to
London England just proven that I know
that pause for applause for knowledge on
to London for brandcast
it's a Google YouTube event and I got to
speak on stage to a bunch of advertisers
and basically tell them how wonderful
you guys are and how amazing the YouTube
space is which is great and I did that
[Music]
good morning I'm going to a rehearsal
for the thing that I'm in London and I'm
on my way
walking through just the most goddamn
beautiful park today London there you
[Music]
it's Jonny I'm here I just did a video
with drinks to wait when will the video
actually got quite soon what a day is
determined you guys will know but first
make sure you guys go watch the previous
videos if they shot with mamrie Hart and
Hannah Hart in which they had them
compete to discover if they enjoyed UK
beers versus USA beers and I was the
deciding factor so it's been a day
it's we've all been through so if you're
having fun open your mouth
[Music]
and while I was there I also slept a lot
and I watched a lot of homeland which
I've been telling everyone that it is
not good to binge watch homeland and
then try to exist in the real world
because you will believe that everyone
is a terrorist and no one is telling you
the truth but Claire Danes and then this
happened and then this happened
Mid West Indies super dark receives key
to city within and then this happened
oh work now I like what roads work not
when there's road work haha
happy Friday Friday reads it is in fact
it is in fact Friday I am headed to a
very cool thing I'm going to do a
podcast with Sophia Amoruso I'm Maru so
I think that's how you say her last name
she is the author of the book girl boss
you probably seen it in every Airport
book store and just every bookstore
that's also not in an airport she is the
founder of Nasty Gal
the clothing and accessories website
that i love and she asked me to come be
a guest on her podcast and I was like
yes and now I'm 15 minutes late I'm
gonna be like 20 minutes late and it's a
terrible first impression and I feel
very anxious about it
but good thing I got my jokes that'll
charm um you told me to go upstairs
I don't know area no idea where to go
worst
finish the podcast she's so cool and the
nesting out offices are fishing
incredible they're so gorgeous office
girls my neighbor has been stripping the
paint from his house for two days so
this is the noise wait here all day
soothing if you think of it like a
gushing waterfall it's relaxing anyway I
bought festive flowers and I'm a pumpkin
I'm gonna be domestic app for a second
okay and now here I am looking at my
laptop on a gloomy Friday afternoon and
I'm feeling things you guys not because
I'm not looking at pornography if that
was where your first thought was it
probably wasn't even where your first
thought when I just assumed that we're
all gross because of the homeland Bend
watching and um anyway People's Choice
Awards that's different than pornography
the People's Choice Awards are awards
that are voted on by you people and I
have been nominated as favorite
late-night talk show host I actually
don't have words to say about it other
than Wow very cool very very cool hear
what the actual favorite late-night talk
show hosts what what what huh I wish I
could double click this and show you my
face like you would snapchat but it's
not so hold on that's a sign maybe this
is so weird I when I was in college used
to intern for Conan O'Brien and now I'm
in
category with Conan O'Brien this is too
many feelings thank God thank God you
start again and I'm also nominated in
the favorite youtube star category among
a gaggle of wonderful human beings first
of all here's first of all here's the
deal you can go and vote on this stuff
you can vote for up to 5 nominees in
each category it says the website so
I'll have links for everything down
below I would love for you to vote for
me if that's what you choose to do it
also love for you to just vote because
expressing your opinion is cool and
interesting in life sometimes most times
it's not fun to be put into categories
or labeled as something unless it is
this specific instance this is very cool
to be put in categories with these human
beings because so many of these people
in both the YouTube star and late-night
talk show hosts are people that I really
think are incredibly wonderful and to
even be on that same level is very cool
and that's enough emotion for me turning
back into a robot don't forget like I
said the beginning to subscribe if you
made it this far it's the least you can
do and if you made it this far you have
really done something important today
[Music]
but I don't know something I look good
my face and I'm like oh my eyeballs are
actually made of glass no I think the
eyeballs